at the start of the movie two primitive
men ventured deep into the forest until
they come across a magical tree with
several glowing fruits on it one of them
becomes curious and takes a bite out of
a fruit surprisingly this causes an
avalanche of changes starting with a
giant snake that lands at their feet
then they are taken to another
civilization where humans have become
much more modern the man who ate the
fruit earlier actually ends up seducing
the beautiful queen of this Kingdom
following this the movie flashes back to
where it all started we are taken to the
Biblical times of early civilizations
where humankind is still very primitive
a group of hunters have Venture deep
into the forest looking for food they
chase after a boar and when the lead
hunter marlack gets ready to attack one
of his comrades is impaled by a spear
suddenly another Hunter named Zed shows
up and boasts about his aim thinking he
has killed the boar after realizing that
he hasn't Zed apologizes but faintly
Whispers that the hunter had blocked his
marlack here's his snarky remarks and so
the hunters grabs that and Bully him
they then return to their village where
we see a guy named o picking
strawberries as marlack walks past him
he belittles oh by tossing away his
fruit basket it turns out that Owen Zed
have been good friends ever since they
were born as they chat Zed spots his
Crush Maya and starts to flirt with her
however she politely rejects him saying
that she wants a man who can protect and
provide for her to make matters worse
marlack offers Maya a Boar's Head as a
token of love and makes romantic
advancements towards her meanwhile oh is
also attracted to Zed's sister EMA but
he is too shy to go and talk with her
just then one of the villagers takes a
dump behind his Ed's sleeping quarters
making him Furious so he and O decide to
take a stroll into the woods where Zed
goes on a rant about how he has always
looked down upon and treated like
garbage they then reach a tree bearing
some glowing fruits it turns out eating
this fruit is forbidden and no one has
even dared to come close to it however
Zed insists on eating it as he
contemplates as to why it is actually
forbidden anyway o tries his best to
stop him but Zed who believes that he
will become intelligent and maybe get a
chance with Maya bites it anyway
immediately Zed claims that he has
gained Superior knowledge but he fails
to answer even the most basic of
questions regarding science at the same
time a giant snake wraps around those
feet making him Panic he frantically
asks what they should do but Zed's
replies are futile and so he eats more
of the forbidden fruit later that night
the villagers have a Dance Festival o
tries to impress EMA and does the
awkward fertility dance with her she
also gets up and dances with oh but for
some reason he hits her in the head with
a stick thinking that she will like it
unfortunately she angrily hits him back
before storming away from there
meanwhile it turns out that someone from
the village had spotted Zed eating the
forbidden fruit and so he rats him out
an angry marlack confronts him about
this and as a result Zed is banished
from the village however things worse
and for Zed as he accidentally burns
down the village with the fire stick in
his hand prompting the hunters to chase
him down he runs for his life and
shortly after marlack finds him hiding
below the bushes Zed is inches away from
being killed when all of a sudden oh
comes to his rescue and hits marlack on
the head knocking him out following this
the two make a run for it as the whole
village descends into chaos oh believes
that the world is flat and once they
reach the mountains they will fall off
but Zed thinks otherwise the next day
O's beliefs are proven wrong as they
discover land beyond the mountains he
then assumes that Zed knew this
beforehand since he ate the forbidden
fruit after a bit of walking they come
across a herd of cows grazing in a field
and Zed decides to kill one of them for
food he lunges towards the cow but is
immediately kicked off shortly after two
brothers Kane and Abel show up and
reveal that they are farmers and that
the cows are theirs as they explain
their work they have a disagreement
which results in a brutal fight in the
end Kane ends up killing Abel with a
stone as Owen Zed are witnesses to this
crime he invites them over to his house
for supper fearing that Cain will murder
them too if they don't oblige they
reluctantly agree to go the same evening
Zed and oh have dinner with Kane's
family the eldest member Adam inquires
about Abel's whereabouts and the trio
lies that they haven't seen him all day
later Adam instructs Zed to sleep with a
beautiful girl while o is forced to
spend the night with a filthy guy Zed is
ecstatic thinking that he will finally
get laid but to his Misfortune the girl
is only interested in other girls
meanwhile oh has difficulty sleeping as
the filthy guy repeatedly farts and
creates a nuisance the next morning Adam
and some Farmers go out to the fields in
search of his lost son they eventually
find Abel's corpse and deduce that Kane
is the culprit however by this time the
trio has already escaped The Village
currently they are at a market where
they surprisingly spot marlack Maya and
Dima in a tied up State Zed and O slowly
approached the girls and learned that
after they burnt down the village other
attackers invaded the place in kidnapped
all of the villagers to be sold as
slaves determined to free them Zed tries
to buy the girls but is unable to do so
due to lack of cash Kane then intervenes
and claims that he can help release all
of them but in the end he simply betrays
his friends by selling them as slaves in
exchange for a horse later Zed Oh Maya
EMA and the other slaves are locked in a
cage ready to be delivered to someone
but along the way a third-party tribe
suddenly arrives on horses and ambushes
the slave masters during the attack Zed
and O break free and luckily Escape
while Maya and Dima are captured the two
try to save the girls and spy on the
attackers from afar but they fall asleep
soon after when they wake up they find
that the attackers are gone much to
their dismay afterwards Zed and O make
their way to a city called Sodom as they
had overheard the attackers talking
about the place earlier the movie then
cuts to a man named Abraham about to
sacrifice his son Isaac due to orders
from God all of a sudden he is
interrupted by Zed and oh who happened
to be passing by to prevent Abraham from
killing the boy they claimed that God
has sent them to stop him hearing this
Abraham drops his knife and thanks God
before escorting them to his village
thinking that they are the holy
Messengers however to prove their
loyalty Abraham states that both of them
will need to circumcise their genital
Parts afraid the two run away from the
village and make their way to the
infamous city of Sodom but they soon
find out that Abraham's son Isaac has
been following them he accompanies the
two into the city saying that he and his
friends always sneak into Sodom to have
fun they soon make it to the gates when
suddenly several guards attempt to catch
them so Isaac runs away while the two
are captured and readied for punishment
but fortunately Kane who happens to be
working as a guard there vouches for
them and saves their lives in the next
scene the trio takes a walk through the
city while Kane explains the perks of
being a guard inside the palace so the
next day Zed and O also get enlisted as
guards despite having no skills
whatsoever after that the three of them
explore the market when suddenly the
city's princess iniana passes by in her
carriage Zed is immediately attracted to
her but Kane reminds him that he has no
chance with the princess as she is
royalty they then head to the Palace
where they find out that a virgin woman
is being sacrificed this is because the
people believe that a sacrifice can
please God and in return they will be
showered with rain food and shelter
after the woman is thrown into a pit of
fire one of the slaves approaches the
three and reveals that princess inyana
has summoned Zed and oh oh is taken
Someplace Else by an old male while the
slave escorts Zed into the palace he
then finds himself in an intimate
Gathering and it's revealed that the
slave who led him inside is actually
Maya after a while Zed spots o covered
in gold paint posing as a statue the two
then see IMA in the crowd who also turns
out to be a slave currently she is being
harassed by one of the guards so Zed
pretends to scold her and sends her off
following this he goes to visit the
princess while the high priest shows oh
the holy room and explains that
whosoever has entered has never returned
alive however it is rumored that only
the special ones will be unharmed as God
favors the righteous ones meanwhile Zed
claims that he himself is the chosen one
and so the princess takes him to the
holy room she manages to convince him to
go inside and speak to God to end all of
the people's suffering when Zed enters
the room nothing happens and he instead
finds oh hiding from the high priest as
the latter was forcing him to do
inappropriate things Zed then kneels
down before the Big Stone in the middle
of the room and prays to God however
after his prayers he gets into an
argument with oh about God's existence
they eventually make up and as they
leave the room together they are met
with the high priest and numerous guards
who put them into jail as entering the
room is against the rules the following
day the two are taken outside where they
are sentenced to be stoned to death in
front of the public but before the
procedure can begin Zed confronts the
king and claims that he is the chosen
one as he is unsca saved even after
entering the holy room as a result the
entire crowd starts chanting for Zed the
king also believes in the theory and so
he dismisses their death sentence but
instead of freeing them he decides to
keep them as slaves later in the
afternoon another virgin woman is to be
sacrificed to God surprisingly the king
chooses his own daughter princess inyana
as he is fed up with her constant
grouching it turns out that IMA and Maya
are also next in line to be sacrificed
and when Zed finds out about this he
makes a dramatic entry and destroys a
construction site in the process at the
same time Abraham Isaac and their troops
reveal themselves into full-scale Riot
Begins the public also starts to
retaliate while some of the guards
betray the king killing him and taking
his crown meanwhile oh rescues EMA and
he finally confesses his feelings for
her which leads to the two having
intercourse amidst the chaos Zed fights
through many guards and eventually saves
Maya from the high priest who falls into
the pit of fire after a while the
fighting style Ops and the crowd all
cheers for Zed as they think that he is
the chosen one it also starts raining
making them even more excited however he
finally comes clean and tells everyone
that he is just a normal man trying to
save his friends he further mentions
that anyone can be chosen and can make
their own destiny if they persevere
through the tough times hearing his
inspirational speech the crowd is sent
into a state of frenzy in the final
scene princess and Jana becomes the
queen of Sodom while Zed and O prepare
to go on different paths oh intends on
returning back to his village to help
rebuild and develop it while Zed wants
to travel the world with Maya the movie
ends with the two having an emotional
but awkward goodbye before leaving the
city of Sodom subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching